hello I think we are seeing the
motorcade approaching I'm gonna step out
of the way here this Eastbound and
Westbound
um Sutherland Parkway you can see I
think this is yeah this is the um
entrance right here you see several um
officers there motorcycles you see
several metro police officers oh there
it is the president motorcade
right there for those who are for for
our viewers we're in Durango in
Summerlin Parkway we just saw President
Biden's motorcade pass us right now
again there's a hard closure here man he
has a big team at him look at several
Vehicles here
other let viewers just take a good look
at this
metro police officer Secret Service
a lot of law enforcement vehicles
if this is the way you take to get home
tonight please look for an alternative
route because this is not gonna work out
for you they haven't we have they
haven't yet announced when these roads
are expected to be back open and
President Biden is expected to attend
we're told a private fundraiser then
tomorrow he's going to be scripture be
speaking excuse me on prescription drugs
so again the president's motorcade I
think the vehicle is called the beast uh
that's what they're calling but again
this is a hard closure here several
closures are on the Las Vegas Valley
because of President Biden's visit
reporting live in Durango and Summerlin
Parkway Joshua peguero eight news now
see what I mean it's very exciting and
real you see the motorcade yeah it
doesn't matter uh it is the leader of
the Free World no matter your political
uh feelings but that is cool and
obviously everything's going to reverse
when he comes back just keep that in
mind uh and then tomorrow as well we'll
keep you posted here on 8 News Now